the third coronavirus stimulus package
has now
passed the house and senate of the
united states
slightly different versions were passed
meaning it will go back to the house for
expected signature tomorrow
but most notably the third coronavirus
stimulus package
passed the u.s senate with zero
republican support not a single
republican senator
voted for getting money to more than
80 percent of americans and getting them
some stimulus during this once every 100
year
pandemic situation that we currently are
facing
let's look at senator patrick leahy
announcing the passage of the bill in
the senate to democratic applause
and i would say republican silence it
actually looks like republican absence
altogether take a look at this
no senator bush has changed the vote if
not the
yeas are 50. the days are 49
the bill as amended is passed
[Applause]
now there are many many things to talk
about here
first of all because the senate passed a
different version than the house like i
said
the bill now goes back to the house and
the house is expected to pass this
tomorrow tuesday
then it will go to joe biden for
signature and then
soon we will see money start to go out
could be within a week could be 10 days
could be a little longer now the bill is
1.9 trillion dollars in total
it includes 1400 stimulus checks
for those making up to seventy five
thousand dollars a year it phases out to
zero at
eighty thousand dollars a year three
hundred dollars per week in enhanced
unemployment benefits
through summer a child tax allowance of
up to thirty six hundred dollars for one
year that that's actually really big and
that's something that
here is being done on a temporary basis
but there are many democrats who would
like to see
um the tax code benefit parents
through making such allowances permanent
and that's something that we can talk
about as well the bill includes 350
billion dollars for state coronavirus
aid
34 billion dollars to expand obamacare
subsidies
and 14 billion dollars for vaccine
distribution now if you have kids
this is a big win for you you would
still get the 1400
stimulus check for each child and for
yourself
plus the tax credit is going up to the 3
600
or 000 if the child is six and older
and there's really a lot here for
families with kids and yet
the bill passed 50 to 49. the reason
it's 50 to 49
is one republican senator was missing
because of a family emergency
had he been there it would have been a
50-50 tie and then kamala harris would
have had to come in
and vote to break that tie kamala harris
didn't need to come in to break the tie
all 50 democrats voted yes all 49
republicans
who voted voted no and this gets into
discussions about the political process
that went into
getting us to where we are today there
are people
rightly frustrated by the watering down
of this bill by democrats
but there are also people reacting to
this stimulus saga by saying democrats
and republicans are the same
and they're equally worthless when it
comes to getting people money that they
need
the first take seems correct to me the
second take
is invariably wrong unquestionably wrong
i share your frustration and believe
it's terrible that biden
said this would happen right away but it
actually will be close to april before
people see money
i understood two thousand dollars to
mean two thousand more dollars
not fourteen hundred more which makes it
two thousand total if you include
the six hundred dollars that will have
been six months before by the time
people actually start getting the 1400.
yeah i i'm with you right there
i hate that the 15 minimum wage was
removed from the bill
i hate that the bill further restricted
thanks to senate democrats who qualifies
at all for the stimulus reducing it from
a hundred thousand a year to 80 000 a
year
this shows us some terrible realities
about the democratic party
including that the most centrist of the
senate democrats people like joe manchin
and jeanne shaheen
they are very soft democrats they're
obviously not progressives
and while they are democrats that
they're not republicans they are
democrats
they're very different than what you and
i might say
is the type of democrat that we want to
see in the us senate but
it's important to remember for those
like there's people mad at the
parliamentarian because the
parliamentarians said
you can't include the 15 minimum wage in
the bill but kamala harris could have
done an override
remember that even if kamala harris
overrules
the senate parliamentarian and says we
are putting the 15
minimum wage in the bill then you look
at the mansion vote
and likely some others and you don't
even pass the bill
at all and no one gets money so there is
a huge critique of the democratic party
to be made here
and it should be made and we've been
making it which is that lots of these
democrats
aren't very progressive at all at the
same time
the overruling on 15 minimum wage
just means it doesn't pass at all and i
don't think that's good either
now on the other hand every republican
senator voted for people to get
zero and look at what still democrats
were able to get done so this is the
other perspective
republican senator ron johnson for no
reason other than to try to delay the
bill although it failed
asked that the entire bill be read aloud
republicans have acted to get people
zero and to make it take as long as
possible
to give them zero and despite that
democrats have uh have been able to pass
and when the house votes for the updated
version of the bill they will pass
a nearly two trillion dollar bill that
puts
thousands of dollars into the bank
accounts of the typical family of four
between the stimulus money
and the child credit it establishes the
country's first
real child allowance it's only on a
temporary basis for now
but there's the possibility it could be
made permanent which it should be
this is obviously nowhere close to what
the american people deserve
but it's important to resist the urge to
self-righteously slam it all
write it off and say democrats and
republicans are the same
this is a major legislative
accomplishment and it's desperately
needed by joe biden
it's not what was promised and it took
way too long and those are critiques
that are fair
so when we equate republicans and
democrats here it's silly
although there are many criticisms to be
made of democrats their positions aren't
even remotely comparable though
morally and legislatively to those of
republicans now if you were going to
claim
that this has merely happening democrats
vote yes republicans vote no
because joe biden is president and if
things were reversed then it was a
republican president you would have the
reverse situation
the answer is obviously not democrats
voted for
every coronavirus relief bill during the
trump administration
not a single republican voted for joe
biden's coveted relief bill and that
yet you still have republicans lecturing
democrats about the need for unity and
bipartisanship and we're supposed to
pretend both parties are the same
so give me a come on guys you've got to
give me a break on that
this is the most loser of loser politics
but republicans and democrats are
nowhere near the same on this let's get
this signed
let's get money to the people let's move
on to the 15 minimum wage and health
care and vaccine distribution
and starting to open things up as cases
and deaths
come down significantly more hopefully
over the next two to three months
and all of the other things that need
our attention
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video